Speaker 1: Let's go to Gabriel from
Albany, New York. Gabriel, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey, David.
Speaker 1: How's it going? It's going well.
Speaker 3: Good. I just had a question because I
live in upstate New York. Yeah, and as you know,
this is a pretty rural Republican area. Oh, yeah.
At least in the more rural aspects. But there's a
lot of people in my surrounding circles that I've
considered, like, kind and especially intelligent
people. As long as I've known them, who have
really fallen prey to a lot of current rhetoric
surrounding the Republican Party. Yes. What do
you think? Really changed in the past probably
ten years because they often spout as an example
of why they don't trust the government as like,
oh, you know, as you grow older, you just
see that you don't trust the government more.
Why do you think there's been such a massive
distrust in government that makes people just like
from skeptical to a completely conspiratorial?
Speaker 1: There has been an overt campaign from
the right to say, you can't trust the government,
you shouldn't trust the government. The government
can't be trusted. And of course, as most
reasonable people know, there are certain things
that it makes total sense to have governments
involved in, and there are other areas where
it's perfectly fine to let basically markets
allocate, direct the allocation of resources. But.
It's been the following combination if we zoom
out is what I would say declining education.
Partizan media. Filter bubbles and echo chambers
that are self-reinforcing on social media
and a complete abandonment of
policy by the American right wing.
And a replacement with exactly the
types of bullet points and talking
points that you're talking about. In sum,
total, that's a lot working against us.
Speaker 3: Yeah. That makes sense. Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right. Gabriel from Albany,
thank you very much for the call. We're
just hearing from a few people. We had
a guest cancelation in it. Let's just get on
the phone and hear from a variety of of great
people. Let's go to Eric from Long Island. Eric,
welcome to the show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Oh, hi, David. How's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 3: Yeah. So thanks for doing this last
minute. I suppose I didn't have too much to say
today, but I'm sure you saw the news about how
Clarence Thomas is starting to cover for Lindsey
Graham in Georgia. Did you have anything you
wanted to say about that? Yeah, I covered it.
Speaker 1: It's the top story on today's show,
which, of course, you wouldn't know because you
are on today's show right now and it becomes
sort of this endless feedback loop. No, listen.
Clarence Thomas, his wife, is an election denier,
a January 6th adjacent individual, in touch with
all sorts of players in the insurrection and the
riots. And like I said at the top of the show,
I won't repeat myself fully, but he should
have nothing to do with any legal decisions
even remotely connected to the November of
2020 election. It's insane that he does.
Speaker 3: Absolutely. Yeah. And it's
actually quite frightening how they're
there. They're actually doing all this in
broad daylight, and it doesn't it seems
like there's not much we can do about it.
Speaker 1: It feels like there's very little
we can do about it, that's for sure.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Well, all right.
Speaker 1: All right. My friend David,
thank you very much. Appreciate that.